my man is up for an Oscar for the
holdovers look at you good to see you
Paul nice to see you it's been a long
time you know in a way I feel like sort
of in your career or responsible in some
small way are I I say that I'm not
kidding that I say I credit you totally
have you already fantasized what your
speech is going to be if you get yeah I
mean I keep thinking I have to have
something to say but I have no idea what
I would do oh I have no idea what I
would say no it's going to be great if
you uh it' be nice yeah well I I I'll
thank you that I'll do that for sure
really yeah sure absolutely [__] you
mean at the Academy Awards sure you're
saying you're going to thank me if I win
that thing I would thank you yes son of
a [__]